um I can't quite run hyper pram sweeps
on the GPU Drive environment we were
playing with
yesterday I did find something to do
though so these are really pretty Jank
um hold on which of these are the red
ones like
non-existent yeah the red ones are
non-existent so I have to just click a
bunch of these buttons real quick and
Hope y we will figure
out which of these runs are any
good all this is normally automated and
summarized for us very nicely on some
graphs but there are some issues with
the environment that prevent me from
doing
that we're going to do this manually for
now it'll only take a minute and we'll
see if we got any reasonable hyper
parameters uh it doesn't look so far
like we have anything great
but uh you know there could
be there could be various explanations
for this welcome link
key yeah so this is what happens when
you have to run all your experiments
individually with like a bash script and
you don't have uh w b to
nicely format stuff for you with sweeps
but we should at least be able to see
something with
done and uh I also I'm kind of
suspecting
that we either have a problem with the
data or we have a problem with the
metric
logging we'll see
even a random hyper parameter search
should probably solve a lot of stuff are
you going to do all no we're only doing
it's the first 200 are the ones that I
ran
overnight though believe me like I have
played my fair share of
RuneScape it's basically the same
thing okay this is about it
so yeah let's take a look at
this okay interesting we see that
there's this like very hard cut off
around
0.14 which leads me to expect that
there's something fundamental with that
value right usually you don't see like a
hard ceiling like this so I'm guessing
that I've probably just scaled all my
data wrong um
episode okay so this one
is know much more
variable some of these are all the way
up at
one yeah I really suspect that based on
this that we just have a scaling issue
and that we're actually solving the
en so I guess then the plan for today
we'll start with a little bit of this
we'll see if we can figure some stuff
out we have all the containers built so
we'll update maybe we'll update our
local container if it's not too
hard
um and then we will go from there
yeah cuz all the data seems to be like
very
here and and then uh the plan for today
will be spend a little bit of time on
this spend a little bit of time on the
Atari hyper parameters spend a little
bit of time on the MOBA
ELO stuff and see if we can start
getting all this into
here yeah we have stuff here I don't
want to get I don't want to lose
I guess then what we'll do in order to
start is we'll go look at the remote one
first and then as part of the stuff we
do today we'll make sure we have our
local in a good enough spot that I can
go from
there I have to rebuild the
containers well not rebuild I just have
to
like uh reup the container with the
latest version has GPU drive support
which is now uploaded by the way you can
play with this uh online or download
it
okay cool
so GPU
Drive uh so this was what we were
logging
achieved is this info tensor sum
item divided
by the number of finished
agents is this
correct let's go look um also I let's
let me fix my my local
uh editor here real quick
okay so it
is there is a log frequency
then for
goals they get
some perk goal achieved
divide by num agent roll
outs self.
locals n.
achieved self. locals N I think it's
somewhere in the rapper Maybe
let's see how they get it is there any
info in
renderer got
[Music]
initialization they don't have anything
in infos
uh trying to figure out how they have
this data formatted
so they do
have controlled agen info.
suum but then what are the
indices that they
worlds
welcome how it
going what is this system for this is a
GPU accelerated
multi-agent driving
simulator uh that we have added bindings
to our own reinforcement learning
Frameworks Library really puffer lib
we've made it a lot faster and now I'm
trying to make sure that we have I ran a
100 experiments on this overnight so
trained a 100 different networks and it
looks like I'm not uh handling some of
the logging data and stats that tell us
actually what happened all that well so
I'm trying to figure out if there's any
discrepancy
there which involves waiting through a
lot of the original
code let me see if we have any
interesting visuals of this I I mean we
don't have any visuals in puffer lib yet
which is my project but this driving Sim
is from uh NYU
group this is python uh this portion is
yeah hold on this is the garbage one
where is it
yeah this thing here so this is their
multi-agent driving Sim uh it has bunch
of cars bunch of vehicles and I've been
doing some work to try to make
this much much faster and easier to use
etc etc and as of
yesterday uh we were able to get this to
about five times the original speed so
quarter million steps per second
training uh with puffer lib and we were
able to make it a little bit easier to
use as well we do we do still have some
work to do thank you yeah we have some
work to do still uh and then after
this this thing is Dolly the actual like
viz that is uh is not mine is theirs the
the GPU driving Sim I do have
environments that I developed myself
will be back on those later today I
think the plan is this followed by some
work on ultra high perf Atari learning
and then once that is in a good spot
we're going to do uh we have to do ELO
calculations for this like miniature
DOTA game simulator that I wrote and
then we'll see where I go from there but
yeah lots of highper environment stuff
around visualization side is a lot
yeah well I mean I do I do write
Graphics uh I do write graphic front
ends for some of my own Sims I don't
have anything that's as high fidelity as
this GPU driving Sim the other one that
I've made recently that will be back on
later today hopefully is can I look up
MOBA on how do I
find is there a search
whatever I can just scroll from uh my
own
timeline wait you're the neuro guy yeah
what's
up let me see if I can find the the
latest thing I've been
doing it's too much garbage on the
timeline okay here it is is so this is a
million FPS miniature version of
DOTA watched your PhD defense eight
times a well thank you I I'm glad you
found it so
interesting there's a lot of cool stuff
coming to this bace now nice to meet you
as well there's a lot a lot of cool
stuff coming to RL now I'm formally
graduated and I'm working fulltime on
making reinforcement learning actually
fast and usable um and I'm doing it
without the constraints of Academia
which means everything goes way faster
now so this is like miniature version of
DOTA Graphics aren't great but a lot of
the features are in
place at a high level it looks kind of
like DOTA right if you just do the low
fire render and we've got a few other
Sims as well that I've been working on
in the past couple of months let me see
if I can find some of
them let's see so we've got
so much Dev okay we've got this big
particle Sim that runs super fast and
let you implement a bunch of basic tasks
we've got particle Sims that look like
this we've
got uh where's the other one the other
one I was really happy with was
snake cuz it's a really nice demo of the
tech okay yeah this so this is this is
basically slyther iio it's multi-agent
snake up to 4096 players I've tried it
with um 4096 agents I should say not
players you can play it though you can
play it against the AIS or with the AIS
uh and the cool thing about it is that
it runs at about 10 million steps per
second single thread and it trains at
over a million steps per second and the
infra that is used in this is pretty
much the exact same as the infra I use
for everything else
and it scales incredibly
well yeah this is here's an example this
is like gigantic snake that's not python
right it's scon so not far off uh it
looks like python but it runs in pure
c yeah there's a really simple text
stack in fact here I'll link it to
you you're going to be stunned at how
simple this
is this is all it takes to do ultra high
perf
engineering so 230 lines of
scon that's
it pretty much looks like python except
it runs stupidly fast I've been using
that stack for everything now and it's
really really good um like the Moa the
whole MOA the like mini DOTA is only
like 1300 lines of
syon waiting on
Mojo I actually think that scyon is way
better Mojo is a language replacement
whereas scon is an extension language
scon has really nice interoperability
compiles to Pure C or transpiles and
then compiles from Pure C has uh some
really good killer features with the way
that they interact with numpy arrays
makes it really easy to have structured
data in Python and then mirror that data
into C so you can edit that data in C at
c-s speed and have it be uh mirrored
everything updated to python without
having to copy the data and have it be
all very simple to
do so yeah one of the plans for what I
want to do in the next month or so cuz
I'm polishing up all these environments
they're in Dev but to release formally
so one of the things I want to do is I
want to get it it's already really easy
but I want to make it like ridiculously
easy for basically anybody who knows how
to code decently well to add ultra high
performance simulators for puffer so you
know if you think about something on the
order of complexity of snake about the
same as like an Atari game right if you
can write two 300 lines of scon plus
maybe a little python wrapper and just
have a stupidly high performance Sim
that you can do RL on at a million steps
per second on one GPU right that could
be a way that we can scale a lot of this
stuff up because there are a lot of
environments out there in reinforcement
learning but now with all this stuff
like none of them are fast enough to be
usable like everything needs to now be
100 times faster than it was before with
the levels of performance we're getting
these days
so that's what I've been up to thanks
for dropping by really funny that
somebody watched uh a thes my thesis
like eight times because I've definitely
I've done that with like stuff I've been
really into before and uh it's funny to
have that happen with some of my own
stuff so cool
started working on trading Bots it's a
good way to lose a lot of money year ago
I decided to focus on Purely RL
for
it
careful it's a good way to lose a lot of
money very
quickly pretty much everybody in RL has
thought about doing this at some
point
um but
yeah definitely be
careful group trading Behavior
to be fair if I wanted to like if I
wanted if I ever wanted to get Finance
people that like interested in this
stuff yeah I would just roll like a
trading Sim thing as an environment it
would probably only take a few
days terrible manual Trader Bots side
has been pretty solid all
right yeah the thing that's always
always sketchy to me with the the
automated trading is like you're playing
an as you're playing an asymmetric
information
game the funds have more data than you
they have way way way more data because
they pay for it they've got like real
time real time geolocation data of
people they like they know how many
people are in the factories they know
all sorts of stuff
[Music]
yeah slightly less efficient market for
now well yeah
now not paying Millions for centimeter
length yeah that's ridiculous
why does this look
like I have it correct
this really looks like I have it
correct but I don't think I
do oh also if you're looking for cool RL
stuff to
read I can tell you layer configurations
no worries um if you're looking for some
fun post some of them are serious some
of them less
so can I link
these I don't know if I can link all of
them directly but if you just I'll link
my uh my Twitter I if you just click on
like the Articles tab I've got like a
bunch of stuff on here some of them are
serious some of them less so but there's
some RL content for you there and let me
move this so I can see so do you mind
the layer
configurations agents had access to a
market to sell and buy things to each
agent have a specific
model uh it's they had some layers for
it it's the way that I did the market
honestly in neural MMO was kind of Jank
it was the network was way too big for
the market it was actually one of the
big
screw-ups um there is some I actually do
have some work coming out on this very
soon and there have been some follow-ups
to nural Mo as well
um basically I had this attentional
thing where you would treat all of the
items as vectors right like all the the
items had different properties and you
would do embeddings for all the
different properties and combine them
and you get a vector representing each
item and then you would have to do an
intentional thing over all the different
items in order to like select which one
you wanted to buy and
stuff and that was just really hard to
learn and was really Jank so I think
that coming up it's going to be
it's going to be a lot simpler but there
still there are definitely issues like
one of the really hard things learning a
market in inside of a simulator like
this is that if you
don't if they don't learn to buy a
specific item and sell a specific item
early on like the network can just
collapse to never using that subset of
actions so you want to have all that the
action space always be used which is
kind of hard I haven't really found a
great way around that yet um
yeah so I don't really have any magic
for this you can look at if you want
something ridiculously complicated that
would probably work if done very well
you can look up uh entity gy and entity
neural networks Clemens has a really
good blog post on this but frankly that
sort of Architecture is just too hard to
do efficiently general purpose for now
um and it's also quite slow so I'm
sticking I'm generally what I've been
doing lately is I've been using way
simpler architectures and just crank on
data like million step per second
training and that's been going really
well early usage is the full action
space is important yep that happens a
lot yeah it's
tough is definitely
tough smaller Networks higher steps per
second yep that's what I've been doing
lately all of my new projects have like
a minimum 500,000 steps per second train
at this point like we're talking we're
like a hundred times faster than my PhD
stuff in this ban of three months yeah
we actually get a million plus for many
of the environments and it's probably
going to be all of the environments a
million plus train single GPU soon and
the simulators the simulators all run
over a million per CPU core not per
machine per CPU core and some of the
simulators run like several million some
of them 10 million plus per core that
snake environment is 10 million plus per
core and trains it over a
million python
multiprocessing I am using python
multiprocessing but I also have
vectorization in
syon so the syon has efficient ways to
run multiple environments on the same
process and then Python's The
multiprocessing but I also actually if
you want like a really nice piece of
content read
this hey we got our first citation from
the GPU Drive paper that's
cool this is the puffer lib paper this
has this has some stuff in it that like
just has not been done in RL before and
uh this is how puffer is so fast like
the perf stuff this shows like 10x
improvements in a lot of cases and it's
actually better than 10x because uh what
happens is as the environments get
faster JY gets slower but puffer gets
faster is kind of cool so we have a lot
of cool stuff in
here but yeah pretty much I've just been
doing I've been building all this stuff
I got bored so I started doing it live
and that's what I've been doing lately
RL is going to be very very different
very very
soon can I
donate if you want to help the project
out out just start it you know follow
the Twitter I really just need the
organic growth at this point like the
plan for puffer is to keep everything
free and open source and then if uh if
companies uh the goal is to get this
stuff so widely used that companies are
going to want extras and then I will
charge them for support contracts and
like uh Priority Access to like you know
features ahead of time or whatever stuff
like that that's the current plan
yeah I also there's going to this is
going to be like um there's going to be
a lot of community open source stuff as
well are you training this local there's
an article on that one of the articles I
linked to uh this is the puffer
cluster this is the the the puffer
cluster it's nothing fancy it's just
eight desktops but it works ridiculous
well each of these boxes is three times
faster than one of stability's 8X h00
nodes for a lot of RL
workloads yeah these things are fast
they each have a 4090 and a high-end CPU
and when you get bottlenecked by CPU a
lot in
RL yeah so this was the other little
investment I made into puffer no they're
Intel I actually think that I probably
will go AMD next cuz I got burned really
bad by the uh the Intel chip stuff right
all the Intel the this gen of Intel
chips being bad I got four bad chips um
yeah so I have to I've got to mess with
some stuff this one here on the end
needs to be sent back to factory
probably this one as well
yeah I know I got four and eight is
but yeah really for the like for people
trying to do cool stuff with RL lately
the plan is to just make it easier and
easier to do with puffer and then my
hope is that I'll be doing you know
first party I'll be deving a whole bunch
of environments and then hopefully we'll
get uh people contributing even more
environments here as well like I've got
uh I've been streaming this stuff a
bunch and I have there's one guy on
YouTube who is already has uh a pretty
darn good fast version of breakout with
puffer that's like 10x plus faster than
the original and we're going to make it
even better than that somebody else I
think is starting on Tetris I think they
might have started that
yesterday
um we're going to have a lot of
environments for this
stuff it'll be
nice I saw using Wan B why do you like
it versus like tensor board never really
likeed tensor are boor to be honest and
WB has uh the really nice thing with WB
is the sweeps integration and
such so the another thing I've been
doing is I've got a carbs which is in
bui's uh
Ultra well freaking amazing
hyperparameter search algorithm frankly
puffer lib is the only one that has this
integrated and integrated with uh any
sort of like logging like this so we
actually can do ridiculously good hyper
parameter sweeps and log them to WB this
is a bad example here this is like a
workaround for an environment that's
breaking um let me see if I can find one
of course I have a 100 that are bad now
but like here this one's probably good
okay so here's Enduro which is nari en
right here's 94 Enduro run Enduro runs
here's the hyper parameter sweep so over
time how much better it gets here are
all the different hyper parameters that
were chosen we can see like stable
regions and stuff we can see
correlations and we have all this very
nicely
done when I look at it I've actually
been pretty busy over the last couple
months as it turns out the more I think
about
it because pretty much none of this
existed like two three months ago
it's been busy weird yeah H it's been
good at
least I don't know I've done this I've
kept in really good shape I haven't done
anything else but uh you know those are
two good things to be doing
worries it's kind of crazy how much the
uh the thesis video blew up I wasn't
expecting that I kind of just put it on
YouTube for archival sake like I posted
it on X and then I said ah okay I'll
throw it on YouTube for archival sake
and uh then it just totally blew up
there huh maybe I should post more stuff
like that
H I might actually I should probably
just post me going through some of the
articles on YouTube as well because like
people don't know that these exist
right I mean some of these are kind of
silly this one is sort of reasonable
this one is actually a really good one
this one is very silly but it's fun and
then this one is like this one is quite
serious this one is very serious yeah
yes you can ask about architecture stuff
sure um the architecture again like a
lot of this stuff is now just in puffer
you can just look at it um it's I
promise you the code is really simple
like people ask me stuff because they're
like well you know there's probably a
ton of code and a ton of stuff that'll
be hard for me to understand there isn't
I write like look I I will prove to you
right now how dead simple this is okay
here's the snake en here's oce open up
torch oh look here's the snake model
it's like what's that one screen of code
here you go it's a sequential it has a
conf a con uh a linear layer a actor and
a value head and then the one other
thing is that there's an lstm wrapper so
there's an lstm that goes between encode
and decode that's
oh this thing so the reason for this is
because it's really easy to shoot
yourself in the foot with the data
shapes uh I hate rappers
too
here I I absolutely hate rappers but
this one actually sort of make sense so
here's the lstm wrapper all it does is
uh it does this really annoying reshape
for you and then it calls your policy
encode and it does the really annoying
reshape it does the recurrent it does
the annoying re shape and then it does
decode so these operations are really
easy to get wrong which is why I made
this wrapper otherwise it wouldn't
exist but here here's another way to put
it like the entire end to end training
stack for something like the snake EnV
is 400 for the environment plus
vectorization adds let's
say another
600ish th000 plus uh a th000 for train
so 2,000 lines is the whole depth of the
architecture from implementing the Sim
to the algorithm everything is like
2,000 yeah so that's why I did that lstm
rapper so nobody would ever have to do
that
again and it just works it works on
everything we use lstms by default on
like every single M now because it's so
easy
there will also be more long form
content on my YouTube uh I'm going to my
current plan is I'm going to make one
video on Puffer I'm going to make one
video it's going to be very accessible
on puffer and like on all of my thoughts
on reinforcement learning and like where
I see stuff going and you know what is
know what's wrong with the field how I'm
fixing it and if that video does well I
will make more if it does not do well I
will not make more videos because they
do take a lot of
time and I would rather be
coding but I am pretty much if this is
the first time you've seen the stream
I'm actually live on here pretty much
every day like five days a week at least
the one exception will
be the uh I'm taking a few days off next
week to go
run for these systems are you storing
experiences to train on no the
simulators are so fast you don't store
anything you just you get the data you
train you throw it away you get new
data are you storing a state in okay yes
you do get State you store the lstm
state but that's
it system uses the last 50 states no we
just have the last we have not the last
state we have the last learned state
right the lstm state not the environment
state so what you're doing there is you
have a fixed window whereas what we have
is a soft window with the lstm right the
lstm just learns to remember whatever it
wants and maybe it does it well maybe it
doesn't but you know we don't do we
don't stack like 50 observations
well I mean think about what an lstm
does right an lstm takes in the
observation it encodes it into a latent
vector and then it will learn to keep or
throw away whatever information on every
step it wants from that Vector so you
can kind of think of an lstm as like
sort of like a soft memory window right
where it will just learn to store
whatever it needs but it won't have
explicit access to all the data
directly soft window is not a term I
just like that's kind of what it
is this is really weird this like
actually looks correct to
second revision of the system was
building remov the input history and
only kept a state history through the
network valid better
data you can look at the way we do this
with just we just have the lstm and the
puffer code it's very
basic just having the lstm only gets
contacts via
States well this is the way I like to
think of it a on layer lstm with poo
solves DOTA so if your problem is
simpler than DOTA and you have a ton of
data you're probably
good that's my reductive
version hey what's up
bet not box
four is it down again or did it never
get rebooted
it's down again it got rebooted okay so
we're shipping both of them stop rail
world yeah no
worries goes down when I'm not even
using it okay well I will tell
okay did you ever resolve the madona
issue um well we got it running on GPU
and it trains it quarter million steps
per second so yes I made their Sim I
made their whole training five times
faster I've let the uh I've I've let the
guy know that uh no it's not that you
need to use GPU actually that wasn't it
at all nice try
though it was a lot of pain and
suffering and cursed things that needed
to be
fixed um yeah so I'll follow up with
them next week I'm I'll try to get it
sent in I it's not going to matter if
they get sent in at the start of the
week or the end of the week because the
micro code patch is not going to be out
for another week
um but likely I'm not going to be doing
anything on Monday or Tuesday because of
marathon uh I'm probably going to just
be in excruciating pain and sleeping a
yes MSI is testing micro code already
it's going to take a little longer
though for that to percolate to like
main gear isn't it well we'll see I
thought that they didn't ship it yet
linky did they ship it down to like um
they didn't ship it down to vendors yet
did
down this send it to man that's to
manufacturers not to like Distributors
right like main gear is not going to
have it for another couple weeks
right
um okay here we go
M gear will have to get it from the
Manas okay so yeah we're good then it'll
go out say Wednesday or Thursday we'll
have it shipped
oh and uh for reference if you're still
here um these two folks here uh are on
the Pokemon project which is uh another
thing that we're doing we're trying to
solve Pokemon Red with reinforcement
learning so lots of Open Source stuff
around
puffer it's going very well actually I
don't know if you saw that one that was
that video really blew up on YouTube um
not mine but like 2 weeks after uh PBS
posted that I started helping with it
and uh been sponsoring Computing stuff
for it ever since it's going very well
really that's all I can take credit for
though these days because bet and linky
and a couple other devs have really been
leading the day-to-day on that I'd like
to be doing more in that project but so
much to
do it's a very well done
video the only thing I can think about
is that maybe I have this done signal
wrong
I was controlled agent mask
this is
right yeah this is
right agent mask is
so um there's some padding in this
simulator and also agents can die
so I'm trying to make sure that I'm only
recording logs for real agents when they
die and something is weird and I don't
know what because the metrics where that
I'm getting don't really make
sense
yeah basically
that oh
well that'll do
it
that I don't even know how I managed to
do
that
well I index wrong I didn't realize
there were three dimensions
Well we I'm happy we chatted about a
little bit
but we uh we got stuff done still and
figured it out
we're on track for
today I was afraid this was going to end
up being like a full day stupid bug
it really doesn't happen that much for
me anymore I got to say especially when
I'm working in my own code bases I
actually very very rarely spend large
amounts of times on simple BG like large
amount of time on simple
bugs it's gotten so much better over the
years but every so often you just have
have to work with something that's just
like got stuff that's screwy this one
was a simple bug and didn't take very
long I'm going to give myself a little
bit of an advantage here and do 64
so I basically think that I've had this
thing working the whole
time well we'll see we'll see what the
curve looks like
this is why I should have rendered
it every single time you should
render this what happens the one time
I'm
lazy did I not do Dash Dash Track on
this good
catch competent at
python competent at programming in
general it's all the same
it's actually really funny in the last
like in the last year or so the method
of programming that I've converged upon
is so like utterly brain dead simple
that you kind of can't do anything bad
with it it like requires you to not
think about any abstractions whatsoever
because you just don't use any and it
works in any programming language
because you don't need any fancy
features for it
works and just look at any of the code
that I've written lately you'll
see okay so this isn't
great it might go back up because I
remember these curves being weird
hey
Nathan I kind of like go look at some of
the just go look at like the mobo code
or anything it's just like one file
scyon of scon with no abstractions
whatsoever it's just like brain dead
procedural code and it works incredibly
well
did you start on the uh you were doing
the tetris end right nus uh Nathan did
you start on
that what he means is having an in
intricate
understanding I
mean can't say it doesn't
um maybe I go find a good maybe what
we'll do is we'll go find a good set of
hyper
parameters from my sweep
before started with pong pong is good
almost there with the end
awesome wait did you actually do like
the acceleration and stuff cuz uh the
pong like acceleration stuff
is it's not just like there is
acceleration it's not just
nothing but hey that's awesome to see
people making new M's in like a couple
of
days was really cool
right why can't I click on
this I should be able to click
yeah you might have to go like actually
find the like the original pong code for
good are these saying hyper
parameters say are these just Jank
these you don't want it going crazy
fast well you want it going crazy fast
if you win on the next
swing yeah J lambda's low but the rest
of them are
sane it's got 512 worlds which is the
fastest
setting I also love that this m just seg
faults isn't that
great I love it when M's just seg faal
on
you I don't know if this is actually
good we'll
see so this says to use a batch size of
pretty low
um BPT Horizon is four which is a little
sketchy but maybe is
fine clip
three update EPO is a little
disappointing
non-standard you're basing your
experience off of
Pokemon update epox is not standard 3 it
depends on your on the speed of
stuff you generally can you generally
can get away with just like if you if
your data is free so your data gen is
just immediate you can often get away
with just having one update Epoch so you
turn through more fresh data faster but
not
miscellaneous stream day we're starting
with trying to get some reasonable
results out of GPU
Drive push a couple
fixes and
um then we're probably going to mess
with Atari a little
bit try to make it super
fast try to like get our our nice sets
of hyper prems and we'll probably do
some stuff with the mooba and try to get
uh the ELO system
working okay so these hyper prams do not
work I think that what's likely happened
is just the um
yeah what would have happened is the
data just wouldn't have been
particularly
sweep can we at least render this
once no because it requires me to Nuke
my local container and re and um and
like like install the new one
stubborn we'll do that after I have made
sure that I have like there's like a
side repo for DOTA that I want to make
sure I have synced and a few other
things I want to make sure I don't lose
anything so here's what we're going to
do
um I'm going to do t-u attach NOP
all
right so that's us covered on this side
this side of
things anything cool okay we get a
little bit of notice on this it's
nice all the GPU Drive stuff is
available by the way um so if you want
to play with it as per this post it's in
puffer tank
it's in just a Dev Branch but there's a
lot of setup so I would suggest using
our container it's really it's a it's a
pain to set up yourself that's why I did
this but yeah this this exact thing this
is going to be the whole deal with
puffer is that it's going to be anytime
something new comes out like this it'll
be literally 3 days before it's 10 times
as fast that's how easy it is with
puffer that's the goal
freaking crazy
prop it's 1047 nut jobs
fast is good because you don't have to
wait around forever or have millions of
dollars of compute to do
research exactly fastest Tesla makes you
go fast paint it red it's even
faster yeah that's good then you get the
speed upgrade right
needed right I remember where we were
with this
I think we should merge the um the MOBA
code right with
Dev let's do that so that people can
have the latest mobu
it and kind of just how I look at it
right
okay so now I can say that everything is
easy to get in the dev
all if we go back to um the puffer
lib directory here
I look for
Moa was this the 20 Bill
run yeah so the most recent run of the
Moa I did 20 billion
steps uh how long did that take us just
for
fun less than 10
hours for 20 billion steps not even
optimized mind you we have not even
fully optimize this um 20 billion steps
in 10
hours just really for
fun
and I don't know it was kind of
interesting it looks like they were
doing something for a while and then
something just sort of
stopped because there's like this
inflection point yeah two Bill steps an
hour get with the times that's like a
minimum
so we can see that there's some
instability
right there's clearly
instability because it's actually
learning very well
here and then it stops taking Towers
it's very odd that it still gets
XP I guess maybe it's still doing some
stuff but not really
much can this be applied to some real
world
ends if you have a really good simulator
that's really fast then yes
so the entropy this is not really an
entropy crash
because five is still high entropy but
then it goes back up to like h
well here's your issue right the value
loss
explodes yeah value loss explodes and if
I recall I think that there were some
really stupid hyperparameters on this
with the value loss
Jank is the learning rate way too I
think they're like they're doing some
weird thing where it's like learning
very aggressively and then just like
clipping the value function down like
crazy
so yeah we'll have to run a new sweep on
this for
sure it's kind of odd to me that this
was any good in the first place
though I guess it's because um the runs
were just not as long so it is good for
the first billion steps or
so funny how these automated sweeps do
stuff like
this we could just run it for a
billion and see what
happens that won't take long right
MH we're going to work on stuff in the
meantime let me see so a billion with
batch
size 2
million we would want checkpoints
every 50 steps right if we want to get
ourselves a nice set of checkpoints
every 100 Mil so we'll set checkpoint
interval to 200
or for to 50 right checkpoint interval
from 200
checkpoint e where's checkpoint
steps this will also get us data to use
with our ELO
system stream is doing well today
welcome
folks all the stuff I'm working on is
freely
available there's docs at puffery I
GitHub there's some cool RL articles
there as
well and all this stuff is freely
available in the dev branch of puffer
Leb
if you want to support my work for free
just start it on the way in helps me a
whole
bunch back to
Dev so we've got um let's see so first
of all do we have
anything let's get some tabs open for
these experiments that we're going to be
monitoring okay so we're going to want
to watch this
one and then we're going to want to
watch carbs
watch your carbs I say while eating a
chocolate chip cookie technically on a
cut we're getting much more variance in
the solutions but nothing great just yet
out of
the out of the sweep but that's fine it
could take a while
so we have a fair number of things to do
in the meantime
um things I'm working on I'll give you
the high level briefly
so basically the whole plan for puffer
for like the next big thing that puffer
does it all revolves around high quality
simulations and really good hyper
parameter sweeps
I think that RL can just go way way way
farther than people think just off of
those two things if you have the high
the high perf Sims we can train at 500k
to a million FPS we can run really
aggressive hyperparameter sweeps and we
can just find really really good
settings
um so in order for this to all work to
all work uh I wanted to show the field
first of all on a benchmark that they
will understand and respect that this
actually is effective so I got Atari up
to 30,000 train steps per second for
reference the default in a lot of
libraries is like
3,000 optimized you know sometimes you
get 10 or something but still huge
performance
increment um so I have run sweeps on
those and we have some good hyper
parameters to look at and we're going to
have to figure out how I want to deal
within manage those it's going to
require a little bit of tweaking to the
way that I manage hyper parameters
probably don't want to do that on stream
now cuz it's pretty boring but I do have
sweeps for the seven classic Atari
environments and um they all do at least
reasonably well and many of them do very
very well like way better than any of
the other baselines just off of the
better hyper pram
sweeps you have to get the scores to get
a yeah we have the scores though I mean
we have we we have we either have the
scores already for M or we will have the
scores because like they're publishing
scores on 200 million frames that takes
them a week to run or whatever so if I
actually just bump up the experiment
length then we'll have those as well cuz
the curves are very clear uh for the
shorter experiments that we have that
we're very very efficient there um so
that is something that we're going to be
looking at for sure I would also like to
be able to the only two things I want to
do with the hyper parameter system at
the moment is I want to make it so that
you can more easily download hyper
uh from wand b as well as have different
sets of hyper parameters for different
M's in the same Benchmark so like
different hyper parameters for different
Atari
Ms that's the only those are the only
two things that I think need to be added
I don't want to do that today because
that's pretty boring um the other big
thing that is preventing us from making
a ton of forward progress is the lack of
an ELO rating
system and what I mean by that is I
don't actually have any any way of
telling if this is doing well or not
right like I can see it's playing the
game and like they're winning it looks
like radiant is winning way more than
dire for some reason but they're
winning um and I can look at
rewards and stuff but like it's a PVP
game right so if both teams are really
good then the metrics are going to look
the same as if both teams are really bad
so I can see that they're learning to do
something like the tower reward is going
up and stuff they're definitely like
destroying towers and the rewards going
up but I don't know how much so that's
what the ELO system is going to be for
so as soon as this thing finishes what
we're going to do is we're going to take
all the checkpoints from the uh the runs
here I'm going to copy these locally and
we're going to figure out how to uh to
get ELO ratings integrated with puffer
it's a little bit finicky but I think I
came up with a decent way of doing it
and I think that that's going to really
be the main piece for the mooba like
that'll help us balance it we'll just be
running some experiments and then
that'll put us in a pretty good spot I
have a couple other Sims as well um if I
would do like the major action items
though it's like there's a little bit of
stuff on the Sim API there's a little
bit of stuff on configs there a little
bit of stuff on experiments to run
little bit of stuff on Elo and that's
about about
it my bad ideas to just monitor more
metrics doesn't
work there's no way to tell Rel there's
no way to tell relative skill in a game
as complicated as dodo without
ELO I don't think I understand what
puffer
is
so puffer is my attempt to make all the
things that are hard and painful in
reinforcement learning that are hard
painful and slow uh easy painless and
fast
so we have a set of very high
performance Sims we have a set of
infrastructure that works with both our
Sims and with any other Sims like any
existing environments that make uh make
it easier to run more copies of those
environments faster we have optimized
training code that is quite fast and
provides lots and lots of log metrics we
have integration with wandb sweeps to do
automatic hyper parameter tuning uh and
we have nice uh pre-built images that
make it easy to manage dependencies for
a lot of common environments as well so
it's just a set of tools that makes
reinforcement learning a lot easier to
deal
with the project was really started off
of this one Insight where I found a way
to make I found a way to make it easy to
to work with complex environments I
found like a way to write a rapper that
makes it really really easy to just make
your RL work with
anything vectorization and clean RL to
do RL really fast yeah kind
of I mean if you work if you work in RL
or interested in RL the best the best
sales pitch I can give you for puffer is
to just say try it because it's very
very quick and easy to do so and you
know once you start using the tools
you'll kind of see all the rough edges
that we've sanded off compared to the
rest of the stuff out
there okay so this is very nice and in
fact this guarantees that we'll have
good data because we'll have a
checkpoint a checkpoint a checkpoint
let's actually start grabbing
checkpoints so we can start working on
stuff
here yeah we're good so I have a custom
M I'm able to plug it into puffer and do
some cool agent training it does faster
paralyzation which gives faster training
yep you get faster
paralyzation you get uh some of our
implementations which make a lot of the
things that are Harden RL easier we have
really easy lstm integration right we
have really nice hyper parameter sweeps
we have really nice local stat
monitoring lots of just nice lightweight
tools um and it makes and yeah makes it
a lot faster at the same time as
well generally I try to get people to
come to puffer for the speed and then
you stay for all the convenience of
everything so it's faster than what else
is like the other stuff that's out there
and then you start using it and you see
that it's actually a lot easier and more
convenient as
well what checkpoints are well this is
just a niche this is like a niche thing
it's unrelated to his question um these
are just like different snapshots of the
model over training uh I need these to
evaluate ELO so for this project I'm
working on right now I need to know how
much better like what's the win rate of
one of these models versus another
that's what I'm about to start on
yeah I mean if you want to try out
puffer there's uh there's a Docker you
can just pull and you get a full Dev
environment complete with all like all
sorts of common M's
okay so we're going to try out we're
going to try to get the ELO code working
on these checkpoints essentially
good I guess the hyper pram sweep was
right these crazy hyper parameters do
work they're just unstable after you
train for a bit with
them it's a crazy set of hyper
parameters
it's kind of cool that automated tuning
can find those though that's like a
psychotic set of hyper parameters no
research would ever manually discover
let's see if this does
anything oh yeah it does do stuff that's
games and we do need to do
update
.5 okay so we just we forgot to update
in place you can't
oh I see you can't choose the trainer's
date
that you actually start getting ELO
updates running single core and one CPU
taken so what I want to do is I want to
come up with um like if no Tower is
taken for a bit we'll just cut out early
cuz some of the early models are just so
bad that they just don't do
so
if you don't take a tower for 2,000 time
steps which is probably very
this we'll see what
happens see they take T they take Towers
pretty
mhm and then it didn't take um a tower
for 2,000 steps
right
yeah cool so this actually works we have
to polish it up
and it has to work for multiple but
I'm trying to think how I want to
structure
this first of all how's this
going this is going very
interestingly look at this you got this
linear growth here which means that they
found a nice policy the rewards are
still going up which means that it's
getting better at
farming ra all rewards going up yeah
this is uh this is quite
good I don't know why radiant does so
much better than dire that's kind of
weird
but I
know so the way I'm going to want to do
this right is
let's just do it easy for now thinking
is hard
send and it elos
uh this needs
a point
D Point
D I don't know why I'm putting this in a
class this really doesn't need to be in
a class really bad habit hard to
thing oh you
also does this even make
sense the way I'm doing
this oh yes it does but it should be
load two policies right not load one
policy
yeah but but here's the thing classes
actually are not great
okay they only seem great because you
have o hammered into your brain like the
moment you start
programming the real reason actually I
know the real reason the real reason is
that uh python doesn't have a nice
struct data type if python had a nice
struct data type I'd use
it really the only thing I want in
Python that we don't have is I just want
to Freon
I think it's actually one of the only
languages that doesn't have a struct as
well most languages
do so I think that the reason I made it
like this is because uh my intent was to
have this thing run on
the current policy that you
so you need to know the uh you need to
know how good a policy
is yeah you need to know how good a
policy is as you're training it so this
does make sense the way that I've done
it
it and then all I will have to do
is uh we will
elos
main a th
and then we'll just do elos here this
has to be elos
equals self. elos
of uh the
it
okay certaint n players equals length of
score
here assertion
error it doesn't make sense right oh
self. elos I have it
wrong so
anything and also we want to print self.
elos not
elos which we did
do oh I see
so elos is going to be update elos and
then
elos self. elos of mine is going to be
elos of zero self. of path is equal to
of
one cool now we'll actually see the
nice now we have to restructure all this
a little bit um I have some better ideas
just need to take a second refresh wake
myself up uh we also have all of these
policies available now which is very
nice so let me I'm going to here's what
we're going to do I'm going to
rewards started going down at the end
you can see this is the last
estimate so interestingly this isn't
super stable but well actually this is
kind of good because we'll see this in
the evaluation so here's what I'm going
to do I'm going to take a quick second
to download these
policies
perfect PT not
Pi
them and this should actually be a
nicely spread out set of elos for us to
analyze
y
perfect so I'm going to take myself uh
I'm going to take a minute I'm going to
be back and then what we're going to do
is we're going to get a really nice ELO
evaluation module for this just going to
be for this DOTA game for now but we'll
figure out how to build that out later
we're going to make sure it works uh
we're going to make it very easy and
clean and fast and then we will see how
to integrate this with actually the
training runs so that we can get ELO
over the course of training as a live
metric and then for use some
sweeps back in a minute
all
right what
H
funny Q
commercial what the heck messages did I
miss oh
silly nothing we weren't no nothing ever
happens it's okay nothing ever happens
right we're going to do some cool stuff
now I just I got to wake myself up
enough to do it
the one thing I've concluded for this
week from this week is I'm no less tired
when I don't run a ridiculous amount
than when I do so I may as well run a
ridiculous
man one thing let me just check
something real quick if I were to throw
in some
types uh if you contribute code that has
types that's okay if you're just going
to go randomly type the whole thing in
puffer lib then no I'm not like I'm not
going to take a PR that's just like
let's type all of puffer
lib see you linky let me just check
something nur's reviews are out and
apparently they're horseshit
let me
see
wow let me see what's the review system
this year
yeah I know this is it this is this is
basically what we
uh this is
basically I didn't even think it could
possibly be that bad that's
insane um
actually puffer lib did the best of any
of the
papers but the fact
on this one I'm allowed to show because
it's my paper and it's it's uh single
blind
wrong this is also
wrong okay so the fact that somebody can
have a a three review on a repo that has
taken off like a rocket in the last 3
months that demonstrably accelerates the
entire field by anywhere from 2 to
100x is
insane is absolutely insane the other
two or six reviews at
least but
yeah that's crazy and the other papers
are even
worse um no I mean this is basically
what I needed to just convince me that
the whole academic system is broken I
will no longer be submitting conference
papers that's my last conference cycle
well done Academia I'm
I don't even know how it's possible to
be that dumb I literally don't even know
how it's possible to be that [ __ ]
stupid it's crazy to me it's actually
crazy to me
it's like I used to think of Academia as
the place where you know you could come
up with crazy new ideas that wouldn't be
supported by industry but it's not
Academia is where new ideas go to
die oh here's going to be the best part
um there's a decent shot that at least
one of these gets into nups we'll see um
but if none of these get into nups I'm
not going to
go I'm just not going to
go I mean if you hate
like if you hate progress so much why
bother I didn't go to RLC this year
because a language model rejected my uh
my on puffer
lib and then the chairs just completely
botched it literally La reviewer fed my
paper into a language model language
model made up a bunch of untrue
statements about my paper submitted it
as review and uh the chairs would not do
anything about it they wouldn't even
assure me that the guy that did that
would be sanctioned like if I did that
at MIT if I like sabotage somebody's
paper like that I would be expelled they
won't do a damn thing academia's broken
no that never got resolved they sent me
one email and then blew me
off and I haven't I haven't caused a
[ __ ] storm about it on Twitter because
you know I know some of the organizers
and they're great guys you know I
respect them but uh it's I'm not going
to be part of this anymore it's a [ __ ]
show like I have better things to do
with my
like tooling is a thankless enough job
as it is like you don't need to make it
any worse like I'm out I'm going to keep
building all this stuff and uh you know
specific Labs if you want to use it
that's great I'll support acade academic
stuff sure but I'm not doing the I'm not
writing I'm not spending my time writing
papers to deal with this [ __ ]
system it's a waste
oh geez those itle e conferences are so
annoying Cog is cool like Cog is a cool
conference the itle E conferences are so
annoying because they they have like
ridiculous fees on stuff
two hours from the beach with the
biggest
we I've done enough traveling that I'm
kind of like grumpy old man status now
and I just like you know don't want to
go anywhere don't want to do anything
kind of just want to sit around code run
lift stay in shape it's about it
let me uh let me just message because I
like the sad thing is with the neural
MMO ones we have so many people on those
those papers were like thousands upon
thousands of hours of
work let me
see I also don't want to go
[Music]
anywhere it's not even the money for me
I just straight up don't want to do
stuff experience have not been
gamechanging enough to validate I mean
they have been good A lot of them have
been good I've done I've gotten like a
lot of my network from them for sure but
it's just like I'm not going to go to a
conference when I where I'm not
presenting something and if they're
going to just make it this ridiculous
right oh jeez the crypto ones yeah know
like nurs and
stuff the the thing is crypto has the
problem that AI is now starting to have
where like that's where all the shills
and like random influencer Bros went and
now they're all hopping on over to uh
you know then they went to like web 3
and now they're coming over to Ai and
they just you know they just smear
hell seriously though like this should
really it's kind of this thing where
this was really demotivating like I had
such confidence in my work when I was a
newer researcher so like I was
definitely the exception where this got
to me less than most people but
seriously like it's just gotten
ridiculous at this point and it's beyond
question how do you look at a paper with
a chart like
this right how do you look at a paper
with a chart like this where we have
support for look all these environments
tested like this right all these
environments it's several times faster
on some of the biggest environments out
there several times several fold speed
up and say nah this isn't
useful yeah only supports they literally
is only supports like atarian like net
hack or whatever like no those were the
two that I happened to change the flag
in the demo code like we literally have
demo code for all of them them I swear
these people do not read papers anymore
I swear it's language
models like i' better hope it's a
language model because otherwise I don't
know how it's possible that people are
this
stupid how do you see a chart like this
and think this is not a useful tool
right how do you see a chart that's how
do you see a chart like this a web page
like this well documented right all
sorts of stuff all sorts of updates
active right GitHub like this this is
the growth on the GitHub people are
using it you have really easy demos you
have containerized code you've got uh
packages released right you've got all
sorts of demo scripts how do you go
through this and then say nah this isn't
useful
how
like it's like the clearest possible
it's not me it's you
insane why did puffer scare
you they're not like poisonous like
they'll bite you and they'll poison you
they're not like snakes right they you
can even like it's not like if they poke
you you'll get poisoned either it's just
don't eat
them oh I see you were I see you were
meing okay but
yeah potential rationale they're very
friendly they're actually very very
friendly creatures they'll come up to
you they're like all they're all curious
they're friendly
see well let's work on
this I wait I should also I should send
a message to that we should sync up on
this
jeez I actually like I'm kind of just
baffled
the thing is the reviews have absolutely
they've gotten worse in the past as well
like they've gotten worse with llms like
we should just cancel the conferences at
this point there's no
point my adviser and I have very very
different philosophies on things um
we got along very we got along very well
on the point of just like both wanting
to do like independent out there cool
research but we have very different
philosophies on stuff um I a much bigger
believer and when something is just
totally screwed up like I will make a
[ __ ] storm out of it
right I won't just take stuff I just
won't take stuff sitting down
right and um especially now that I've
graduated and I no longer have like my
lab's reputation to think about like
yeah
ridiculous now I hope that doesn't
change as my age like seriously shoot me
first
like the only way I've ever been able to
make progress on anything is just by
being incredibly frustrated about the
you know the default right like puffer
lib neural MMO all these projects don't
come from a place of like I just want to
build cool stuff they come from a place
of like looking at what is out there
seeing how utterly and ridiculously
broken stuff is and saying okay well
that can't be it right we got to fix fix
this it's just how I look at
stuff like I look at it as like you know
the glass is half empty but I can fill
the glass
right okay let's uh let's start on this
so we should just do
actually this should just be roll out
instead of roll out right roll
10 yeah we're going to we're going to
change some stuff here
opponent how much stuff do I want to
pass here so you pass the
policy
opponent yeah this is good
and what we'll do
is don't need games
played don't need
this put this up
ah my my mind is still on this the
stupid reviews that's just so irritating
and the funny thing is last year I had
um last year with my work I had uh three
papers all get in I believe it
was we had like a perfect uh a perfect
review cycle I think it was I think the
puffer paper still the puffer paper got
rejected but the project was way less
mature
then um it was still ridiculous or
whatever
but like that I honestly think it's that
like the reviews have become language
models or something I don't understand
why else
okay let's uh let me see if I can get my
focus back here
so I just want to return the scores
basically
right hey what do everyone up to we're
implementing an ELO
system for the miniature
and there should be
no yeah this is going to be return
[Music]
none return
none Okay cool so now what we get to
do is we get to figure out how to work
this logic into the main thing y so that
we can tell which models are better than
which other models right now there's no
way of telling which model is better
than another we need a way to play games
where one policy controls one team one
policy controls the other team and we
see the win
rates that's what we're currently doing
so then we can have a training curve
that shows us over time whether we're
actually getting better at the game or
not
okay so we
have knit
elos checkpoint directory
exponential curve means it's shroud
yep
Strike I'm sure he'd be good at it right
regardless
okay used to play league and doed during
Pro
days as a pro or just I didn't know that
so
continue
um uh ELO
pair
array
path pair
scores there this is
good all right was cool going to go
study back to back next stream cool see
you around
we also need to load the opponent
right opponent path load
policy we should do checkpoint dur up
here checkpoint
yellows all
right is this
better I think this is better
right do
name and
name H I don't think we've had four on
twit before that's fun
opponent I probably forgot to delete
this self AR didn't I yep every
issues this is also kind of single
purpose because we're checking like
specific game conditions instead of
infos this is good enough for
now so it
runs some
victories well we're also using the
worst model as a a starting point
yeah let's print the game in the
opponent a time minus
okay did we get anything cool out of
this let's see so it selected a bunch of
opponents and then it says
that no towers are
taken let's see why that
is so we do a reset
right radiant victories
it seems like something weird must have
happened there definitely should
be I mean the solution is really to just
render it isn't
well ocean.
torch oh well I'm giving this to the I
don't even know how that
quars okay
it should be render mode
see look at this
Speedy Speedy Gonzalez
print this will be
good
welcome red is radiant I'm guessing let
me see bottom left should be radiant
um let me fix this so the chat's not
covered by puffer fish
winning okay so you can see it's playing
against the first
checkpoint and dire Victory red is dire
dire is top right
okay and then this one it says that no
Towers were taken which doesn't make any
sense that no towers are being
taken because I see literally right here
right I see them attacking Towers
let me see if it takes more than 2,000
steps
resetting well that definitely looks
weird me doesn't
Towers now it looks like they're just
going past the towers but the thing is
they should be hitting them on the way
so the towers should be getting
taken let me just run it for a way
longer let's just like
let's just see if it just takes way
longer than I
think so the thing is the first time I
spawn the environments I randomize the
health values of some Towers I think
they did just take one didn't
they that's really weird where did the
tower
go they should take this one
right well where's this this one there's
this one's
missing it's not going to be a graphical
bug one of them might have eaten it
somehow I don't know
I'm very new to RL and machine learning
in general I'm interested in training
algorithms on more complicated
environments like yours but I'm clueless
about where to begin well I would S I
might be a little bit biased but I would
generally suggest starting with puffer
lib because I built it specifically for
this
purpose um hold on one second
mode
human uh that's
weird
um this is where I will show you for uh
for starting points
here so we have all sorts of
environments oops
here Dev
Branch so the Moa I'm working on right
now is here the snake en is a really a
simpler but really high performance en
policies are in here puffer lib takes
care of the rest and the source code is
relatively short and quite easy to read
so this is where I would take a
look if you want to do
that kindly start the repo on your way
in helps me a ton
Action the cool thing with puffer is
like unlike other projects
um it's going to be really trivial to go
to from simple to complex Ms that's the
whole thing with puffer is like it
scales so well with environment
complexity that it's essentially simple
and complex Ms are the same thing in
Puffer
see well that's
okay just take the render pram out
MOA and
uh I don't know puffer
strike uh this was not what we
intended we have our AOE
heal okay ready to
recharge how did it just ignore the
tower what how did what just ignore the
tower well we're getting like attacked
with some abilities here cuz these
things are just murking me
hell we just stunned it in front of the
tower that was
cool we can stun them
see stunned him can't move and then the
puffers can take him
out that's pretty cool
right this is annoying I forget what
this bug
is can we just like let them win I want
to get to the second game to see what
the heck is wrong
oh yeah it still resets you randomly
doesn't it
okay well I did damage to the
tower so it looks like it
works yeah there's the puffer blink
striking onto my
right okay so here it looks like it
breaks when they
win which is funny let's fix the render
you're not kidding about syon just got a
500% speed boost yeah it's way faster
it's way more than 500% I'm guessing you
didn't even do it right um if you do if
you build with annotate it'll tell you
when it's calling back to python if you
have no yellow in your program then then
it's running in pure
up hey make some cool ends toss them in
puffer see what reinforcement learning
comes out of
it I get all sorts of people like you
see constantly right ask asking me like
how to do stuff in reinforcement
learning like if you actually want like
if you really want to learn RL fast just
like start adding stuff to puffer
because this is where RL is going super
fast and
like there's not really anywhere else
you can go that people will just like
look at your stuff and like submit PRS
to fix it live on stream
right I've done that with uh uh with
Noah's Tetris en I'm sure I'll be doing
it with Nathan's pong en like if you're
doing stuff that actually is going to
like benefit the r like open source RL
in general yeah I'll just like fix stuff
and PR stuff it's pretty easy at this
point for
me offer only not valid for proprietary
like industry stuff proprietary industry
stuff you got to pay for the the extra
support everything else is
free what is the thing you said about
yellow in
scon so if you run with annotate right
you just you compile with the
annotations and you look at the HTML
file it shows you in yellow every time
it calls back to
python have you caught up on any of the
work from RLC yet nope not really
monitoring anything um I assume that
there's just going to be a deluge of
Twitter stuff over the next couple of
days and I'm just going to wait and then
I'll like sift through you know whatever
ends up being good once uh once that is
over
like I'd be at RLC right now if um you
know if they had reasonable
reviewing so I'm not going to be
too quick to have to like you know go do
all the stuff looking through it
damn it these freaking
Bots hold
on there we
go major difference between Python and
syon syntax wise well you have to type
your code that's the main
difference other than that they look
pretty
similar what happened I must have missed
it
well um you know how they had a a
technical review and your senior review
well my technical reviewer didn't read
the paper he fed it into a language
model it invented a bunch of typos that
were not in my paper that made my work
look really sloppy I got like a you know
slightly positive like a like a
borderline accept from the senior
reviewer and then based on you know the
reject the biasing like reject review
from this person that didn't read my
paper and made stuff up essentially
sabotaging it and then the like the
lukewarm second review I got a rejection
out of that with no uh no appeal process
for like actually sabotaging my work and
not even a guarantee that you know they
would sanction the reviewer I mean if
that's a university student he should be
expelled from his program
so not really going to go out of my way
to support
yeah the only reason I haven't blown him
up more on Twitter is just because of um
like I have respect for the organizers
and what they're trying to do so I don't
want to like smash the conference too
hard on
socials I actually should have done that
that's the sad thing is like if I put
the llm structures I bet you I would
have substantially higher reviews on
some of these papers like it's reviewing
is a joke these days
yeah they just invented their whole
review was them inventing a bunch of
typos that weren't in my
paper oh you're streaming on Twitch now
I'm streaming I'm on X twitch and
YouTube you can watch wherever it
doesn't matter it's just jarez 5341 same
as my
Twitter yeah bet bet here star is is BET
is uh BET's right yeah I mean I'll post
them as well I just haven't wanted to
like post them all over Twitter out of
mostly out of respect for Eugene cuz
he's one of the organizers and he does
really cool
work yeah latency on Twitch is
better I don't really care where people
watch as long as you start the
repo I heard they ask for references to
their own papers that's
funny but I was expecting the nurs
reviews to be better this time around
and they were actually just as bad if
not worse so
um I think that at this point probably
llms have just infested the review
process and it's like not worth writing
papers
anymore I think that's probably just the
state of it I mean you could solve this
problem overnight just by sanctioning
people right like if you're use if
you're not reading a paper that you're
assigned to review and you're just using
a language model then you've signed up
to review for no other reason than being
able to put it on your resume you're
actively sabotaging people's work for
personal gain you should be expelled
simple as
that I mean a lot of these are grad
students right
you know you if it's a company person
you uh you inform their company and if
they have too many people from the same
company you ban the company from you ban
the company from the conference that'll
fix it real
quick like these are not hard problems
like these are incredibly incredibly
easy problems it's just like you have to
make a firm call and nobody wants to
make a firm call like ever on anything
it I tried you know I tried changing the
like I tried to help with the process I
did some stuff for NPS I tried to make
it better this year like I ended up
actually getting some language changes
made to the call based on stuff that I
did but it's still it's just like at the
end of the day it's a reviewer that's
going to do whatever they want like I'm
not without being able to make way
heavier handed change it it's not worth
trying to change the process like the
best thing is to just like say screw it
and go WR open source code and just like
okay fine you're going to be this way
we'll just slowly replace all of this
stuff with like with better things
right not even slowly very
quickly like okay you're going to
require that you know you have SIM like
you have experiments on like these
really old slow environments that are
outdated fine we're going to just write
fast environments and get better results
uh way easier and way cooler because our
stuff isn't slow like we're just going
to do stuff that way
now what happened
here invalid
um grid two
I bet that this is when you destroy the
ancient
right why would it be when you destroy
the ancient though that this happens
reset is it when you reset the
environment that something
breaks that actually would be very
substantial wouldn't it
what happens when we reset
so all the towers get
creeps
oh yeah this is probably bad
how do you uh how do we check
this when we Loop
over when we Loop over
creeps we just check their pids
right so when we reset we should do res
spawn
guess
yeah okay so this is actually
fine so what we'll just do is we do four
I in range of num
creeps get creep
I
PID get creep
yeah that's
fine let's see if this does
it so this should null all of the extra
creeps and uh we'll see if that is
enough to fix this
it's kind of cool that this is sort of
fun to play as is like I
can decide that I'm going to stun a
creep hey what's up there
puffer see
stunned and whoop let's uh let's let
them win the game
they actually have learned to use skills
effectively as well which is really
cool
H still invalid
pit all
right I'll
bite and see what's wrong
right get level level two at 35 XP is
kind of
weird that looks like there's a bug
there right do I get level three just by
killing this
one okay at least I don't get level
three
so there might just be an off by one
it's not as big of a
PID
-1
at
99 48
type I can't figure out what it is I
thought it was like just a win the game
thing but I think this is actually a
legitimate bug in the
environment we'll find
this little mobit today is
fine it does randomly it randomly
resetting you is a little
obnoxious I think that we're not going
to need that for much longer though
I think the it's that's almost outlived
its
puffers everyone over to Twitch today
that's
funny well welcome twitch
folks in case the marketing wasn't
obvious enough the towers are stars and
the characters are puffer so please star
the puffer on GitHub
I hadn't even connected the dots on
that I don't know how much more obvious
I can make it man what do I do I
literally have to implement DOTA and
make the tow stars and the characters
puffers as a marketing stunt and it
still doesn't
work I kind of find that funny though
just like making a bunch of Sims that
are like actually high quality like full
games or whatever but the graphics are
just like puffers and
stars probably it would be better to
actually make the game look good but you
know who's got time for that
I could think of some ways to Jazz up
the map just a little bit at the very
least
it would also would be nice if the
puffer at least flipped you know when
you go forward or backward that'd be
cool I could do
that just waiting for it to crash so I
can get some error
logs I thought they were yellow
dots me maybe I need to make the Stars
bigger the puffers are creeps and the
heroes oh dude what's your RuneScape
combat
level I forget if it's 125 or 126 it
might be
125 I forget if I didn't max
prayer I also have yeah I had to it's
like heroin dude that game is heroin
um I have like 700 completed raids
I think like two or three Bill Bank
Inferno Cape Twisted bow Scythe dusted
omlet yeah that game got me
good okay invalid pit negative one on
tile
it is a tower
tile that's
right oh yeah I remember I got the
Master's Helm and I was working on my I
was working on GM tasks before it was
like okay that's
yeah I did some pretty cool stuff
though did um day one hard mode toab
completion that was cool
so somewhere a tower is getting reset
incorrectly is what's happening here and
we need to fix this so that I can
evaluate ELO correctly and like I I Al
assume that something it's probably this
is messing up training
somehow I wouldn't be
surprised there's like some Edge case
here that I'm not
seeing
right it should be respawning all the
towers
112 and 34
is like probably it's not actually
always the same Tower it's been
different Towers so I'm assuming it's
not spawning any of them
correctly Tower do spawn y let's see
when we make these how we make them
fine okay so here is the Tower data
right spawn X spawn y
PID think Tower pit is fine right yeah
it's the same get Tower of
index tower. Health gets set to Max
Health Tech timer get
zeroed move
to spawn y spawn X
right f move to
um that's a little bit
annoying but I'm pretty sure it's
that I think this is it I'll explain
so uh towers are actually coded as tile
Types on the
sense no wait that doesn't make sense
because you do set the T you do set it
to
empty oh but if the tower is already
still alive
one something is just screwing up the uh
the respawn of
towers if we can fix this then we'll be
able to fix the rest of the stuff it's
only 2 p.m. uh we should have plenty of
time today to get ELO
working and several other
things I will say that the movement
actually feels pretty good in
this like just having it be Point like
this it's not the same as like an actual
mobile where you like click around to
move maybe it's just because I haven't
played enough that that that movement
system always felt like it's very
precise and stuff but it feels it just
doesn't feel good to
play right like obviously you can't play
a mobile like this like you need to be
able to click to move instead of drag
right like this is way jankier for act
like playing well but it does feel
really good like the movement feels
really good
and if you just put the cursor anywhere
around your character it uh it stops you
moving just anywhere in the like the
general
region you can go slow you can go medium
you can go
fast I'm also getting sniped by this guy
here is one-shotting
me is there a way to speed up the
simulation yes
there is I'm concerned I might miss
something okay so here is the
error it actually did not
reproduce so it's not what I thought it
was yeah I thought I was about to fix
it
um this is so weird because this is a
tie like this is a Tower
position does this go
down this might just go down
what does PID stand for player
ID it's just your order in the loop
essentially everybody has a unique
ID it's just your order in the loop here
let me make it faster because I can I
could actually do that very easily it
makes it hard to play but who cares
for once I actually do plan on being
live tomorrow as well so hopefully we
should be able to make a lot of progress
here um where is
is I will be
um I will be out at the start of next
week for a bit it definitely Monday
maybe Monday Tuesday Wednesday probably
like Monday Tuesday would be my best
depends oh okay here actually look we do
we get failed to respawn
issue faed to respawn every single one
of them actually
the thing is because the original grid
has
hold
on does the original grid have the
towers I don't think it does
right no the grid shouldn't have the
towers on it
right yeah now the grid doesn't have the
towers so why then would this be failed
let's try
this maybe this tells us
oops invalid index for type bloat
move um not really back to MOA this was
supposed to not take super
long and it really shouldn't I'm just
sort of
being I don't know I'm being slow
today we use a few days
happens I would like to know how my team
is getting so strong when they don't
seem to be doing anything I guess it's
because they're just fighting the creeps
at the base
right cuz I'm not getting any
XP I guess they must yeah they must just
be fighting the creeps at the
base I don't know how they got they got
level 11 already that's kind of
ridiculous did they take the
tower what the
hell well that's
weird uh uh the the game not
respawn because the grid is already set
to two which is
Tower so for some reason
I don't know why that would happen for
all the towers though that's
weird 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
nine 15 16 yeah it's all the towers
it which should set yeah it sets the
grid to
empty so I don't know why the grid is
two on
everything well I think that probably
I don't want to do this manually though
it's
like what if I just
do grid
it the working hypothesis was that like
if the tower is still alive I clear the
player ID off the board I clear all the
player idas but then I don't clear the
towers off but it looks like it looks
like they're both not getting cleared
correctly
friendly reminder that you can actually
play with this environment right now if
you want it's uh free open source and
very easy to set up in puffer
lib so million of million step per
second
mooba single threaded plus Integrations
with AI technically you're playing
against AI right here as well your
teammates by default these ones kind of
suck they'll be get better though
release some good models
[Music]
soon soon as we can train
them can I heal my teammate
puffer yeah heal the team
puffer oh there's our ancient the
ancient is open
happen where are
they uh I saw some
puffers oh they just took a chunk out of
it
ocean that doesn't make any sense
because the point of
the point of baselines is to track is to
save a is to save like the best version
of a specific policy if you want to edit
the shell script you can just edit this
edit the shell script
though right the quickest way is just to
edit the shell
script it is not
magic you can just open code and change
things it's good
because dash dash
Baseline
means oh I see what you mean yeah but
the dash dash Baseline that argument
that says track this run and Mark it as
the best run so that when you do eval
with D- Baseline that's the policy that
gets downloaded by default
PID but wait now it's on tile
10 what's tile
10 radiant o
because hang on a second wait just one
minute
Magic for newbies is there any
documentation to get started with puffer
I would certainly hope
so I put together this whole
website talks all about the stuff that
we
have and then if you just look at the
GitHub repo
itself this also has some
commands and
stuff if there's other docks if there's
other stuff you're confused about that
you think that there should be docks for
let me know cuz I got I could add more
stuff I just don't know what to add I
don't know where people get stuck
because people don't tell me they suffer
in
silence how are we on Stars 765 is
pretty
awesome why is it that when I post
something like this this gets more like
this gets way more noticed than when I
do something really cool like you know
making a driving Sim go Stupid Fast
there's like a lot of what the heck how
do I have what let me reply to some of
this stuff what the heck
clickbait contribution along with the
papers
stuff carbs probably this site might
have some good stuff by now as well
right well let's not let's not totally
Focus break on this let's let's finish
this part first first um so I see what's
happening like somehow the board is just
not getting cleared correctly that's
essentially the the deal here
[Music]
um
so the thing I'm not understanding
is the issue is in render
here I do I call a
reset before before I compute new
OBS and
then inside of reset right
you reset the grid to the original grid
right
here there shouldn't be able to be
invalid PID on tile 10
right spawn player
let me see what's respawn
me invalid PID on tile 10 this is like
the radiant
carry am I not copying this grid the way
I think I am or something
rig
grid is grid.
copy oh is this
it I think I was missing this copy here
hold on I think this might be it I think
I was I was altering the original grid
sense I think I might have V I think I
might have just found it you might have
just found
uh
okay still
invalid did this
rebuild yeah it looks like it
did invalid pit on tile nine
just making sure that there's nothing
I'm not going nuts here there's clearly
somewhere that the board is not getting
get cleared between resets which would
totally mess up training and would
explain a lot of the weird stuff that
we've been
seeing okay well that's
interesting um
H that's
interesting that this doesn't
owe you a beer or some subs speed is
everything I get it
now I do meet up with folks I'm
currently in the Bay
Area but
like like I'm not I'm not looking to
fund all this stuff off of individual
contributions right the goal here is to
just have have all like the like the
open source St side be fun times uh
everything is free you know tribute code
if you like help promote if you like
that's all helpful and then the goal is
that companies will want to pay for
support contracts or support or uh
services around
it that is the
goal how's the mobile looking mobile is
looking good we're trying to find a bug
in it right now something is weird with
when I uh I reset the environment and
then as soon as I fix this though I'll
be able to basically have ELO working
and then as soon as I get ELO integrated
with wandb sweeps I think that's GG like
that's the one missing component to have
all of this just hypers
scale in Austin that's like the one
place I haven't been I haven't been like
I don't have I ever been to Austin at
all I don't know if I have I'm jealous
of the food that you have there I'm very
very jealous of the food that you have
there
I mean it depends what you mean by that
right I like
uh I like a lot of just like No Frills
down to earth food right I'm the type of
guy like I will gladly go to a diner
like every day if it's a good diner
chill Mexican place like casual whatever
you know that type of
yeah I know they're not I can't find any
darn diners in California it's crazy
like I can't just walk down the street
and go to a diner it drives me nuts
I got a a few good spots here but that's
about
later okay I think I'm going to do a
quick I got to do a quick thing at 4M so
I got an hour and a half to fix this and
then I'll be back later in the
evening people are posting puffer Li
around and just like
random stuff is
cool that's
funny puffer to the
Moon absolutely puffer to the Moon
error
uhoh really
see this is the cool thing about being
able to just do stuff on stream like
this um that's a 30- second fix right
no I appreciate the reports because like
if you just send me a big queue of these
in a Discord I'll never do it like I'll
just never do it if somebody just like
hey can you just fix this right now I'll
be like yeah sure
come on we got to be able to fix this I
want to be able to at least have a cool
result for the stream before my meeting
in like hour and a half and I got to do
one or two things in between as well so
let's say we got like an hour
10 to do this
this
um and to get ELO
working lock in for
that okay so this is this is clearly
wrong right like when I
run eval ELO like this having copied the
grid like the Sprites are all vanished
like everything is still happening but
all the Sprites have like vanished so
that's
bizarre uh oh so you can't
do right you have to you have to copy
this data in like
this I think that that should still be
fine though I don't think that I'm doing
anything weird
you when you call reset you do update
the grid to the original
there's no alternative explanation right
than the grid
getting not getting refreshed
how does a reset work that's different
from the first time you call
it tile
7 radiant
assassin definitely a reset
bug so
wait you pass grid here
right and then this is the same as the
grid we pass into the
niik equals
this for
tile
equals
red if tile not
in
unique got a pen
tile try this I'm just going to print
out the unique tiles see what's in here
after you
reset just got to start printing more
stuff
right is spaces supposed to
converge yeah it is I've noticed that
there's something weird with it as
well you can go run a quick hyper pram
sweep to see if there's something wrong
yeah I saw that um I something changed
with it it's actually probably a bad
thing uh if you want to go figure that
out that would be
awesome
but it should take like all of 10
minutes to run a full hyper pram sweep
on it to see if it's just hypers
okay so unique tiles is one and zero at
the
start and we're going to see if at the
end we still have unique tiles
stuff let me see if I can get him to add
something to
all right let's see what
happened ah we see right
here so somehow we're leaking
data this original grid is getting
mutated that's incredibly incredibly
weird
original grid is equal to grid.
copy you would think that that would
copy the grid
got to run thanks for stream yeah see
you
around
um numpy copy not copying is this a
thing copy. deep cop Cy I don't think
you should need that
to be fair you can actually drive a
little bit and have stuff be cheap
farther out in Texas right there's a lot
of space
the also the funny thing is if you think
about it
like wait there are some people in ml
that cast doubt now on how far RL can
take us and some of the
Practical limitations in terms of sample
efficiency what's your take well if you
want to get really really practical
right currently 99% of the resources in
all of AI are being drained into
language models I think that whoever you
talk to nobody's going to tell you that
like language models are guaranteed to
solve everything a lot of people think
that it will but a lot of people think
it's like 50/50 at best right it's just
the most promising thing that they know
about at the moment so I'm putting like
comparatively no resources into this
thing and I'm getting really far and
compared to language models like RL has
had so little investment and has shown
so much promise based on that tiny
amount of investment like people were
talking about compute and Sample
efficiency on DOTA years ago right in
2018 2019 well guess what DOTA Is Now by
modern standards a tiny project you
could do it on like 200 modern gpus at
most probably less than that so really
RL has solved crazy problems that
language models have not even been able
to approach with next to no investment
whatsoever
years ago
right as for practical limitations like
sample efficiency I'm sitting here
coding million step per second
simulations and they're not simple
simulations either right like I can
basically take a reasonable version of
any modern game and I can make it a
million steps per second per thread like
per core so like we could make all of
DOTA one to one pretty much still would
be hundreds of thousands of steps per
second
started hey I honestly I think puffer is
going to be the future of RL and uh so
far it seems people
agree growth has been insane on this
project and I really am just getting
started with
this aren't their purposes different
yeah completely different as
well my in my head like the most likely
case is that language models are going
to take us ridiculously far much farther
than many people would expect but it's
not going to be able to do everything
because it's not grounded by interacting
with a fixed simulation or a fixed
reality right that's what RL gets you it
lets you learn by trial and error with
something tangible something real it's
like the difference between doing stuff
and just thinking about doing stuff in
your head
right also these things scale
fundamentally differently like RL takes
tiny little neural networks on tons of
data whereas language models right
supervised learning it takes gigantic
networks on like practically no data
like language models train on no data
they have no training data at all
like 10 terabytes are you kidding me I
train on that in one GPU overnight like
that's what RL does on one GPU overnight
it's night and day
do I have to Define all these sweet
parameters by hand no they get inherited
from default so you only have to update
the ones that you want have different
ranges from default
let me open
[Music]
something uh that is for the uh driving
environment GPU
drive this is just a bizarre error
there's some copy going on I don't
understand how this is
possible original grid
this is called once in underscore nit
right and then when we call
reset what's my eval code
doing eval code only makes the end once
right yeah we only make the end
once we do explicitly reset multiple
times which is a little
weird but that's it's not terrible
right wait yeah no that's
bizar we're going to go back to headless
mode here for a little bit
love the positivity I would not describe
myself as positive
whatsoever but sure uh most beautiful
data pipelines come from RL
projects remote distributed training I
also wouldn't describe the data
pipelines is beautiful either Shez I
haven't seen that one
C Z's remote
distributed I don't think anybody has
cracked good remote distributed training
in RL
right that's still
unsolved we're currently at a million
steps per second local one
GPU it's very hard to scale
that because you know you're at the
point where you have like microc seconds
like microc start mattering the optim
izations get
hard okay what happened
here so unique
tiles unique
Victory unique tiles so original grid is
getting mutated somehow
oh I see what they're doing it's one of
these okay these are really hard to
do it's really hard to do these
efficiently
interesting can finally beat
pong my pong AI with the
ball wait do you have a model train
that's good
don't understand how this
is data is getting mutated
mark question
mark
this
wrong python
do sweep carbs I haven't I haven't been
maintaining the original sweep as well
do sweep Dash uh sweep Dash
carbs you'll need to clone just like
clone the it's puffer lib uh puffer a/
carbs just do that in a different
directory pip install d e dot it takes
two seconds
Branch might not allowed to keep a
memory view around like this
don't know that they solve distributed
RL but they sent a client
system yeah to generate selfplay
work but you still can't use it for
training
properly I can only automate rollouts
it's very
difficult do we know how much data how
much data was Alpha zero trained
on this is probably already really fast
right
o That's only 2.8 billion steps there's
no way it's this little data
right do you know how many actual like
how many states like how many states of
Chess or whatever this is played on or
not was this chess oh this is chest not
go okay
carbs only compatible with
3.10 it's compatible with 311 I use it
on 311 all the
theirs okay there isn't to pit package
so you can't do
that you're installing something random
I'm pretty
sure I told you what to do I said to go
download it and then pip install d e do
not try to like download a
package the fact that this is getting
screwed screwed up is really weird to
good and then when it plays the next
game it's
bad for
billion so it must be because of the
um the search
then that like because it's doing MCTS
at every step because that's like no
data 2.9 billion like I can
train I could train on that much data in
let me think how big is a chest
board or is it was this go or
chest I don't know how big is a chess
board small right it's like 11 by 11 or
something how many freaking pawns are
there is it 8 by 8 yeah it's 8 by 8 oh
that's tiny yeah I you should be able to
do I could do 2.9 billion steps in an
hour I could have thought about it for a
second if I yeah and just counted like
the back row I don't know how many pawns
there are but I could have gone like
okay one two three yeah
eight I've been streaming too much I
guess causes brain damage
I think I must be looking in the wrong
spot there's just no way
is
pup
look you did this right you cloned carbs
you pip install that she dot right and
then you
went back into puffer like this or did
you put it in the same directory is
puffer li like a fool
you put them in the top level so like I
have my stuff like
this I think I forgot that this is not a
memory view right this is um
second is it really not install you're
in puffer town
you didn't get any install
[Music]
nothing yeah no there isn't there
shouldn't be in the puffer carbs you
did you pip installed carbs not puffer
right no I said don't pip install I said
don't pip install carbs I said pip
install d e dot
look here not inside of puffer Leb they
both need to be pip installed they're
separate
packages pip install
here it will install perer tank carbs it
will build and then you will have
successfully built
carbs I said if you pip install without
the Dashi you're pulling from a
repository online that doesn't exist
it's somebody else's thing that they've
named carb separately L that has nothing
to do with this
how have I gotten stuck on something
this simple for so long
well I have to
uh I'm going to take a few minutes what
I'm going to do is I got to go do a
couple things I'm going to take a few
minutes I'm going to come back I'm going
to solve this and then I've got a
meeting and then I'll be back after that
but hopefully before my meeting we'll
have solved this I just got to go do a
couple things be right
okay 800 search simulations per position
yeah so
he should keep the chat on the be right
back
screen good idea
here uh let me see how to do
that
Rowser
oops there you go
actually let's put
this this up
[Applause]
go multi- discreet has no attribute
n what uh what do you run bet for
that do you find yourself using LMS in
this work a lot no they're garbage
they literally can't do anything the
only thing I use for the only thing I
use is I use super
Maven
like you it pretty much just gives you
one line Auto completes fast and they're
not particularly good but like it's
really good for just saving typing
that's about
it okay I'll look at that in a second
does train work and sweep not work
better is it like the whole l
I want to figure out what the heck is
cursed with this first and then I will
be happy to fix
okay um I'll fix that bug for you and
then yeah let me just fix that real
quick because this is going to take a
little
really did something change cuz it works
on
um let's
see you have a different version then
cuz this is not what is that's not what
is in this
file I don't think it's the P I don't
think it's
syon are you on the dev
Branch I mean
there's none of these should be being
used
carbs
Branch yeah carbs is in Dev now man
everything's in Dev I migrated
everything up I just left the branches
in case I needed to I usually only
delete branches once per minor release
in case I need
hold on I'm stuck on this and this is
driving me nuts let me figure out what
the heck is wrong with this
think well let's just run this and see
first of all if I've magically
[Music]
yeah it's still
broken how's the m going
Nathan I don't know how this is getting
copied this is so bizarre
it's like it's getting in knitted
multiple times or something bizarre
like it doesn't make sense
works what did you add to the hyper Prem
to the sweep configuration
bet
nothing I might not hold on I'll fix
that then in a
second I think I fixed this bug let me
see yeah that was really stupid of
[Music]
me sometimes you're smart sometimes
you're a [ __ ] I don't know what to
make sure it's still
good look at that
okay it's not detecting wind condition I
don't
others and I can fix that actually
because it shouldn't be
the first game I randomize everything's
Health it's to break symmetries in
training I have to reset it a second
time to get rid of
that but still
actually it shouldn't be harder or
easier
can we render it now or does it still
blow that up cuz maybe we can render it
and see what's happening
worked so does it work or does it not
work when I take the
eval I don't know if I
did I don't think I changed anything
well it says dire has not one right
here right no look the ancient is gone
and it's not
one I saw them pulling it as
well I saw them like moving the towers
around which we know that they can do
that I got to say this is a really cool
to look at like this is a really cool to
watch Sim isn't
it it's going to be cooler eventually
like we are actually going to make it
look a little better than
this we're not going to go crazy with it
but we'll do like some low you know some
lowf cool
stuff um so I think that this is a legit
bug in the game then
right this would actually explain a lot
if you think about
I bet they're like healing it on the
same tick or some
[ __ ] this should be negative 1 not
zero
do you see that they just moved the
tower it's a feature not a bug all
right it's a
feature we just watch this for a bit and
see um if this changes anything
well this health thing was more
intuitive so let's leave that like this
I got to go make my shake CU I have to
hop off for a meeting in a second sec
let me try this and then what we'll do
is I'll go for my
meeting we'll try this I'll go for my
meeting and then I'll be back
afterwards for another hour or two
probably unless it goes really
long but we should be good
well this is running I'm going to
oh
interesting well I think it says that
the tower is still there it just like
got absorbed
somehow but like how did it just get
absorbed
is all right well um I will be back in
hour hour and a half something like that
for a little
bit um we got stuck on a bunch of bugs
today but it's okay it happens uh so all
the stuff that you see here is again
this is all
available right
here in puffer
lib I'll put
the repo
up so feel free to try it out and uh
please if you haven't already St the
repository it helps me out a tremendous
amount actually uh more than you would
think with just these metrics normally
so yeah I will be back soon uh
hopefully we uh we can make some
progress